I'm John [inaudible] and
this is history two o two.
And so I'm here every
Monday and Wednesday,
10 30 to 1120.
And the way this course is that,
that these are all really major themes.
And I'm going to go over this a little
bit and I'm going to talk about some of
the themes,
uh,
and I kind of lecture on things that I
think that compliment what you're doing.
Let me give you an example.
Uh,
when I talk about imperialism,
the new imperialism,
why it is that Europe,
uh,
basically took over the entire
world between the 1880s and in 19,
uh,
14,
I,
if you can read the chapter,
I have a history of modern Europe,
which I had fun writing.
Um,
but I left her on the boy scouts and
I often say that I lecture in the boy
scouts because I was thrown out
of the boy scouts and a Portland,
Oregon when I was a kid because I didn't
manage to accumulate a single badge and
was totally useless after sports seasons.
Uh,
ended up,
but that's not why I do it.
Because to understand the new
imperialism one has to at what,
why Europe took over.
Essentially all of Africa that
had places were totally uncharted,
uh,
suddenly became a highly
contested between British,
French and German and Italian,
uh,
conquerors.
Uh,
that one has to understand that the
culture of imperialism and the origins of
the boy scouts in Britain
has a lot to do with that.
Why generations of British youth and
their counterparts in Germany and,
and even Australia and New
Zealand and other places,
uh,
began to think that it was important
to me to look at a map and their school
house,
uh,
that,
that had the color red for Britain.
Uh,
increasingly taking over
the map of Europe and,
and lots of other places.
I mean,
of,
uh,
Asia and Africa and lots
of other places as well.
Uh,
so instead of at the very
beginning of that lecture,
I'll say,
look,
there are three things you really ought
to know about the new imperialism.
Why,
why they did this.
And then I talk about,
uh,
the boy scouts so that those
two things will fit together.
Or when I talk about World War
One and we'll have two lectures.
My friend and colleague Jay
Winter is doing one of them,
uh,
on the great war and modern memory.
Uh,
I,
instead of trying to do the entire war,
and there's a,
I think quite sporty
chapter on that in the book.
Uh,
uh,
I'll talk about about trench warfare
and you'll see a film called paths of
glorious in early a Kubrick
film about the mutinies in 19,
uh,
in 1917 and I'll talk about the
mutinies in 1917 when people just said,
enough is enough,
you know,
there's no sense dying for nothing.
We won't go over the top.
So,
which is to say that,
that it's important to come to lecture
and it's important to come to sections.
I've cut back on the reading.
I used to use about four
more books than I use now,
but it's better to concentrate
on what you're doing.
Uh,
the books are a history of modern Europe,
uh,
which I basically the second edition,
which I wrote for people like you.
Um,
and then you'll read Persian letters,
not all of it.
That would be a rather lengthy,
lengthy day or so,
uh,
you read excerpts in person
letters and Montesquieu,
you know,
talks about in a way it talks about
relations between West and east.
And it's really a phenomenal moment
in the history of the enlightenment.
Um,
and you have a pause where you,
you're,
you're basically just reading me,
uh,
for better,
for worse,
but I hope for better,
uh,
until you get to Emile Zola as
great novel as you know me now.
Uh,
which is,
uh,
which is the classic that a lot of
it was the first sort of naturalist,
a naturalist novelist,
uh,
at least in France.
And when he wrote Jeremy,
now,
Jeremy,
now it means budding like
the budding of trees,
but he means the budding of,
of people being aware of themselves as,
as workers.
He went down to the mines in the
north of France and the Amazon.
And one of the heroes,
uh,
of of the book is a woman called Kathleen,
who is 15 years old,
but it's seen a lot of life
from being 15 years old.
And when Zola,
uh,
wrote,
Jimmy,
now he went down into the
minds to look at 15 year old,
uh,
young women,
barely older than girls
are working in the mines,
uh,
12 hours a day.
So it's a book that just,
you know,
it rizzone's with reality and
it's really kind of an amazing,
amazing,
amazing book.
And I think you'll like that.
I hope you will.
Um,
and then helmet Smith's,
the butcher tale is about accusations of,
uh,
of ritual murder in a German town.
It's about,
about the,
the second German hike,
uh,
and it's about,
antisemitism in a small place
with bigger consequences.
Uh,
George Orwell,
I went off to fight the good fight in
Spain during the Spanish civil war.
Uh,
where was sort of a dry run for a even
more horrible war and even more horrible,
uh,
a fascist.
Um,
and it's about his engagement
and disillusionment,
uh,
in,
this the Spanish,
uh,
Republican forces of the loyalist
forces and about the tensions and the
duplicity of,
of,
of Stalin's folks,
uh,
undercutting the trustees and
are cutting the anarchists in it.
It's one of those classics as a
classic for a very good reason.
It's really a,
a,
a marvelous reed.
And finally,
there's the ordinary men.
Uh,
I go to Poland a lot in
the last couple of years.
I've been there four or five times for,
for various reasons.
And I'd never been to Auschwitz.
And,
uh,
I went to Auschwitz a a year ago.
I don't know.
Some of you would probably had been there.
And as you're going through this,
the horror of it all,
and as you're seeing,
you're seeing empty suitcases
with people's names on them,
that people don't exist anymore,
and you're seeing baby
shoes and things like that.
You think who could have done this,
who could have gone out,
uh,
and simply,
in assembly line way killed
people or in fields around woods,
which is a,
was a large industrial towns,
still live in Poland,
simply gone out and blown
the brains out of mothers,
babies,
grandmothers.
And anyway,
they found who could have done it.
Well,
the answer that Chris Brown,
he has his ordinary men and he had
the brilliant idea of looking at,
uh,
a German unit,
essentially policemen from Homburg,
uh,
the town,
the port town of Hamburg,
old important Hanseatic port.
And he follows them from the
lives of very ordinary people,
uh,
into the killing fields.
It was nothing less than that of Poland,
you know,
and it's also short here,
middle as long,
but these other ones are short and,
and,
uh,
it,
it's also,
you know,
it's gripping.
It's,
it's,
it's quite,
uh,
quite amazing.
So,
uh,
those are the books,
I think the history of modern Europe.
I hope it's fun to read.
Uh,
I think you'll enjoy that.
And the lectures kind of,
you see the themes as
speak for themselves.
Um,
sections that everybody likes.
Wednesday night sessions.
Uh,
one of my colleagues has only
Wednesday night sections.
Uh,
and we've got increasingly to that
because sometimes you don't find a large
audience on even Friday morning,
10 30 slots.
We've abandoned that.
So tentatively we're going
to have two at seven,
two at eight,
and then a Thursday at 1:30
PM and Thursday at 2:30 PM.
And I don't know,
when are we starting sections?
It doesn't,
sometimes we don't do
it till the second week.
It depends on what date,
what day is this Wednesday.
Um,
so I dunno,
maybe we'll start on next week.
We can,
maybe we won't.
Who knows?
But they will happen.
And,
and uh,
uh,
there's also a short
sporty paper assignment.
And by short,
I don't mean two pages.
Uh,
but,
uh,
but something like seven pages,
eight pages on something
that you want to write about.
Now let me give you some examples
just off the top of my head.
If you have any interest in,
in painting,
for example,
it would be interesting to take a,
uh,
to take a look by say the impression to
impressionist painters like Pizarro and,
and,
uh,
um,
and when and wow,
and to see how they viewed the
transformation of 19th century Paris,
the big boulevards and all of that.
Or you could take another novel.
I mean,
Jeremy,
now,
one of the interesting things
about it is that it's a,
it's a document of history.
You know,
it's a novel.
So these are invented people,
but,
but it's a document of
history in some ways,
as is lots of the great
literature on World War One.
And there isn't any period in
modern history that has so much,
so much gripping literature
about it as the great war.
The British war poets
like seek recess soon.
And a lot of these people were,
you know,
were dead after they wrote,
uh,
as soon wasn't least immediately.
I can't remember if he
dies in 1918 or not,
but,
um,
uh,
to take,
to take some of the poetry or the writing
of the war and write a paper about it
or if you're in a diplomatic
history or something like that.
I mean,
I don't know.
I wouldn't counsel paper of reevaluating
the origins of the Crimean war.
I that might you put you to sleep before,
you know,
it puts your ta to sleep,
but don't know.
You could imagine a good,
uh,
a good paper on that.
I mean,
you can do whatever you want.
Um,
one of the lectures and
when I do the enlightenment,
a burn from my good friend Bob Darnton,
uh,
you know,
I'll do a thing at the beginning about
why the enlightenment was important and
what it is,
the secularization,
rational inquiry and all of that
stuff that you may already know.
Maybe not,
but it's the,
it's in the book.
But then what I do is
I look at some of the,
the third string,
kind of where the third division in the
European football sense of enlightenment
hacks,
uh,
and what they wrote about royalty in
about aristocrats and the way they kind of
undermine those traditional hierarchies
that would be swept away to a large
extent by the French revolution.
Or you can take somebody out of the French
revolution such as the steely sounds
used and who ran off with his mother's
silver at age 16 or something and one on
the grand tour of France.
And,
and talk about him and the Committee of
public safety that signed away the lives
of lots of people,
but may have also saved the revolution.
You can do whatever you want it.
Well,
you know,
it should have something
to do with the course.
And in the time period
where we're talking about,
I mean,
I think I,
you know,
and on the red sox or something,
but,
uh,
you know,
work with your teaching participant in it.
You know,
I'm an email animal.
I'm always available on email and I have
office hours as well that people don't
come to the much anymore.
I'm sitting there doing
nba.com because email is made,
office hours sort of oblivious,
I mean a a irrelevant,
not oblivious,
but uh,
people are oblivious to my office hours.
But anyway,
uh,
they are,
where,
when are they are Monday
is the one to two 30.
You used to be three,
but I sit there by myself,
one to two 30.
Uh,
in Branford College,
a k a k 13.
Um,
there are also two other movies when we
get to fascism when we get the odd off
Hitler,
we and,
and,
and he was only one of a
whole bunch of dictators.
There was hardly any
parliamentary regimes left in,
in,
in continental Europe
by the time 1939 comes,
uh,
a woman called Leni Riefenstahl
who just died in 2002 at age 102,
uh,
she in,
when she was a young woman and did a
propaganda film for Hitler and Hitler.
Mussolini believed in high tech.
He's one of the first people to,
to use the radio.
And we,
Franklin Roosevelt used the
fireside chat or the radio,
but Mussolini was already there,
you know,
uh,
piling fault.
So it upon false hood,
uh,
and,
and Italians who can barely afford
to eat a all had the radios.
And the same thing that happened in,
in Germany as well.
And she did a book,
she did a movie called,
uh,
a documentary called triumph
of the will about Nuremberg.
And it is truly chilling is an amazing,
uh,
it looks like in on a political
convention or something.
Uh,
uh,
in some ways,
and it's,
uh,
all of these movies you can
see in the privacy of your,
your,
uh,
luxurious suites and Branford or Pearson
College or wherever because they're
available now in ways I
don't even understand.
But,
but on your,
on your Internet,
we used to actually show them here.
Uh,
I used to use this movie,
a great movie called
the sorrow and the pity,
the show.
Glad I let PTA and it was
four hours long and the,
and people describe it as a two,
six pack movie.
I end,
the janitor is complaining because there's
so many rear bottles rattling around.
Of course,
this was before the drinking age was Lord,
of course,
a Lo of her was raised.
So of course,
uh,
I don't show that movie.
I,
I take that back.
I don't take that back,
but what the hell.
But anyway,
uh,
I don't,
I don't show that movie anymore,
but,
but I do show a triumph of the will
and you can watch that at home.
Uh,
and that the other one is a of lollies
on phone because one of the last lectures
I talk about resistance and collaboration
in Europe and because I live in France
much of the time I talk about France,
uh,
and,
of Wiley's on fall.
Some of it.
Goodbye children.
Uh,
some of you have probably seen,
it was made by Louis [inaudible]
who just died a couple of years ago.
Uh,
and it was about when he was college,
he was,
so,
he was equivalent of
seventh and eighth grade.
And there's a new boy shows up at school
during World War II in Fontainebleau,
which is just south of east of Paris.
And he's a boy who hadn't been
there before and he's a Jewish boy.
And it's about his
friendship with this boy.
And what happens at the end.
It's not a happy film,
but it's like,
it's a great,
great film.
Um,
what else?
But to say there's a midterm,
I don't like to waste the
lecture giving a midterm.
I would rather give a lecture,
but we have to have something,
uh,
to report to you.
Uh,
if you,
if you a tube.
But if you don't do very well at all,
we don't count it as
much as if you do well.
Um,
I people ask these questions.
I know how much is it worth while,
I mean,
Geez,
if there's more to life than grades,
but it's,
uh,
it's,
it's something like 25% and the is 25%
and section participation is 10% whatever
we work out.
And then,
uh,
and then the final.
So,
um,
it's just,
you know,
it's an exercise in seeing how your,
uh,
how you're doing.
Um,
and it,
you know,
it really is,
is,
is no big deal,
but it will help you pull the themes of,
uh,
of the course,
together.
And it's no scary situation.
I mean,
we all live in the sort
of a minus B plus range,
you know,
I'll tell you,
a couple of years ago
I ran into the student,
uh,
when I rented a student,
something,
you know,
friendly guy.
And I see people say,
Hey,
well how are you?
How,
you know,
how are you?
And I ran it.
It's one person said,
hi,
how are you?
And she went,
oh,
hello.
Oh,
and I remembered her name and I went and
looked it up and there was a B plus and
it wasn't that,
hi,
how are you?
A minus or a one.
Uh,
but I mean,
whatever,
I'm sure she had all A's and the other
courses and a B plus is not the end of
the world.
And most people get A's.
But,
uh,
whatever.
But you have to take the midterm.
Just the way they run it
here and it's not my idea.
So that's what we're going to do.
Okay.
Now I'm going to talk about
seeing some of the themes.
And then at the end,
I'm going to read you
a poem because I got,
I started history in a way,
in a serious way because I read this poem,
so I'll leave that until the end of it.
Um,
I didn't go to Yale.
I went to University of
Michigan maize and blue forever.
Very sad,
eh,
since last weekend.
Um,
and uh,
I could,
I came from Portland,
Oregon.
I don't know if he would
come from Portland,
Oregon,
but that's where I'm from.
And when I went off to Michigan,
I had been at a Jesuit high school and
just what the high schools for it was a
sports factory in part.
Uh,
but,
but it was a very good school,
but it was very repressive.
And I went off to University of Michigan
after having gone to a Jesuit school
for four years.
And,
uh,
it was wine,
women and song and there weren't
enough of them in the middle.
Uh,
and
probably too much of the first
and my first semester I got,
um,
I got a 1.9300000000000002 grade point
average and my mother asked me if that
was under a two point scale,
you know,
I'm sure his,
and I had a,
I had an F.
I mean I'm not,
I shouldn't laugh at myself and my kids,
the,
Oh my God,
not the same story again,
but I got an f and I got two cs and I
got a B and the people I hung around with
in Anarbor,
we're so unaccomplished some of them
anyway that they thought I was smart,
can I got a B?
They say I go by in the dining room,
he got a B and they,
they asked me to tutor them.
Can you imagine that?
And so,
I mean,
some of the people that I
hung around with were amazing.
You may even know people like that,
but I don't think,
I don't think so.
But one of the guys that I knew,
I got to get back to
the topic in a minute,
but I just thought of this was a sure.
The King of Malapropisms and,
uh,
one day he was going on and on.
This is the people I hung around with.
He was going on and on
about this good meal at,
he'd had,
you know,
of one course after another and it
was fantastic and it was a really good
restaurant.
And,
and you know,
somebody snuck him some wine and,
and financially I,
they're tired of the whole thing.
I said,
was it gratis?
And he said,
no,
it was chicken.
And so those,
those are the people that I hung
around with the University of Michigan.
But I've tried here a long time.
Uh,
and I stand by maize and blue.
But I love Yale.
And one of the things I love about Yale's
being able to teach people like you,
and I mean,
and I love this course,
so I hope that you will,
you will enjoy it if indeed you take it.
Now,
what about some of the scenes?
What kind of stuff are we good?
Are we going to do,
could you get some,
uh,
um,
a syllabi for some of those
folks back there be great.
They're up to,
they're up on the the thing.
Thanks a lot.
I'm a couple of scenes.
Um,
I don't believe in,
I've never believed that
history is a series of bins.
I guess I wrote that in the book,
but that you open up and you say
whether it goes enlightenment,
shut that baby down,
then you open up the next one and here
comes 18th century rivalries and you shut
that baby and then French level Lucian,
while I'm on,
I know all about that now.
Pretty soon you'd go on to Russian
revolution eventually and all that,
that you know,
to do a course like this where you're
going to learn much of what is important
to know about Western civilization.
I do believe,
um,
to do the reading and stuff
and if you enjoy the lectures,
um,
there have to be some Fred's that no,
they go to all the way through that,
that make it work then make it worth it.
So you something and,
and one is certainly state making because
even if you take a sort of federalized
decentralized state,
like with this very bizarre electoral
system like the United in the United
States,
uh,
that the growth of,
of modern states,
you know,
it doesn't really just come
to the 20th century with,
with the welfare state beginning in
England and even before that in some other
places,
insurance programs and things like that.
It begins with the
consolidation of state power,
uh,
in the late middle ages with,
with territorial monarchies,
the Spanish and the,
and the French and the English monarchies.
Uh,
it has a lot to do with the growth of
absolute rule and that's why I'm going to
talk about next time.
Absolute rule.
Uh,
absolutism,
uh,
the growth of standing armies,
huge standing armies,
never seen before,
uh,
force big forts built on frontiers.
Uh,
it has a lot to do with bureaucrats
who could extract resources from,
from ordinary people.
While the rich didn't pay anything
or hardly anything at all.
Uh,
it has to do with an allegiance,
the dynastic legions that
can be transferred later to,
to,
to a nation,
the idea of a nation.
And that starts in the 18th century.
It doesn't start in the 19th century.
It starts in the 18th century,
at least in England.
And that's an argument that we in Britain,
and that's an argument that we'll make.
We'll make bef uh,
also,
you know,
in 1500,
which is kind of when
that book gets rolling,
they only started about 1648.
Um,
there was about 1500 different terror,
Touro units in Europe and some are
no bigger than archbishops garden in,
in Germany.
And some were larger states.
Not yet what they are
now in terms of size,
such as France and,
and uh,
Eh,
uh,
which expanded under Louis,
the 14th it into,
you know,
Alsace and,
and,
and Lauren and,
and various other places.
But there's about 1500
territorial units in 1890.
There were 30.
And so the consolidation of state power,
which is looking at it
from the state out or the,
the,
the emergence of an identity where you
see yourself as German as opposed to a
Bavarian French as opposed
to Gaskell or Provence,
Sal,
uh,
Spanish as opposed to Castilian,
or as opposed to cattle [inaudible] the
cat law language was illegal until 1975.
It's 75 until a Francisco
Franco finally Croak,
uh,
in 1975 and November.
Uh,
uh,
and so,
some,
somebody,
this is a great phrase,
some,
I wish I had said it originally,
I don't know who said it,
but someone once said that a language
is a dialect with a powerful army.
And that's it.
That's true.
France at the time of
the French revolution,
half the people in France,
new French,
there was bilingualism.
You could know Katella.
You could,
you could know over in Europe,
Patois,
we live in the south of France where a
lot of people's old people still speak a
patois though now that's mostly dying out.
Uh,
and how does it come that identity,
a sense of allegiance
to a state or a country?
Not everybody,
but how does it come to 1914 when
people marching off to get killed,
uh,
thinking they're Macias and
the French national anthem,
uh,
in,
in pretty good French.
How does that happen?
How does the state increase its reach?
How does the modern world,
how is it created?
We call this process,
it's a clumsy world word,
but state making.
How does states form?
And the other side of this
is how do identities change?
If you,
you know,
in the 16th century,
17th century as somebody who we were say,
who are you?
And they say,
well,
you know,
I am so,
so I'm of this family or I am Protestant.
If it was the 16th century or late
16th century or late 16th century,
where anytime after 15,
twenties and thirties,
and parts of Germany,
I'm Protestant,
uh,
I am Jewish,
in much of the Balkans.
I am Muslim,
uh,
in most of Europe.
Uh,
I am Catholic and eaten in Eastern Europe.
I am,
you know,
Russian Orthodox.
I live in a village,
Mir,
uh,
in Russia.
How does it happen that by
the end of the 19th century,
people have you in Russia as
they're starving to death,
a starving in the famine that the Tolstoy,
the great writer called
the world's attention to,
you know,
they,
a lot of them died and in fields thinking
only if the czar only knew that we
were starving and that his
ministers were treating this bad,
how angry he would be.
Well,
they didn't get it.
That the,
you know,
that they didn't know that this
art could have given one damn.
Uh,
but,
but the,
the allegiance to the czar,
that sense of being Russian,
uh,
or being dominated by the Russians are
something they had to be constructed as a
w.
So the state constructs its ability to,
to,
uh,
to extract taxes,
extract bodies for national armies,
also to provide resources.
But identities are transformed.
And so I give this as an
example cause state making is,
is one of the themes that kind
of ties everything together.
And you know,
this course a ends in 1945 but look at,
look at the problems and
the post communist world of,
of state making and look
what's going on in Georgia,
which is more complicated than,
than,
than the newspapers,
uh,
present in very many ways or look what
the horror show of of the Balkans in the
1990s.
So a lot of the issues,
uh,
religious hatreds that
we thought only were,
would be limited to Northern Ireland.
You know,
that's another theme that's very
important to the whole thing.
Another,
as of course is economic change.
Obviously this is not a
course in economic history,
uh,
but the rise of capitalism,
I mean,
that's what it's called,
capitalism or large
scale industrialization.
It changes in ways that,
that,
that will suggest in the reading.
And then I'll talk about a little bit
the way people live in very fundamental
ways.
There's lots of continuity's,
but there's lots of big changes.
Everybody has an end up in
the assembly lines right away.
Uh,
and there are other ways of,
of,
of other rural production.
Uh,
a women's work,
uh,
remains terribly,
terribly important.
Uh,
and I'll spend some time doing that.
A very dear friend of mine,
my mentor,
Indeed Chuck Tilly,
who just died a couple months ago,
my great sadness once said that it's very,
it's bitter hard.
It's bitter hard to write
the history of remainders.
And so lots of people who
were left out of all of this.
I'll do one lecture when I talk,
I talk about popular protest
and I'll take three examples of,
of people rebelling and I,
I stand back and said,
what does this mean?
What is going on here?
I take the example from,
from the Pyrenees mountains,
a place called the edge.
We're not responsible for
that name would never be,
but we're suddenly men dressed as women
carrying guns or carrying pitchforks.
Came down out of the
miss out of the snow and,
and drove away charcoal burners
and drove away forest guards.
Why?
Because they'd lost access
to glean to pasture.
They're,
they're miserable animals.
Uh,
because the wealthy big surprise got the
law on their side as the price of wood
goes up.
They didn't walk around and say,
well,
I'm a remainder.
Eventually I'm going to
have to move to Toulouse.
And my grand,
great,
great grandchildren will work in the
El Spatialos in the air industry.
Uh,
there they didn't say I'm
remained a number 231,
but they fought for their dignity and
for a sense of moral of justice that they
thought existed at one time that had
been taken away by economic changes they
couldn't control.
And then I take an example from the
south of England from the same time,
1829,
1830,
when they say they're fine people that uh,
dead with only dandelions and
their stomach dead of hunger.
And then these people start marching.
The poor,
the rich and poor rural labor start
marching and threatening people with
threshing machines.
Why threshing machines?
Cause threshing machines was taking
away their work as harvesters.
And one day they found a sign that said
revenge from the is on the wing from thy
determined captain swing
suggested that there were many,
they were righteous.
They were just,
they were armed.
They were ready to
Catherine's swing exist.
Of course not.
They were weak and they get lost there.
They get defeated.
Some of them are Hong,
lots of them are sent to Tasmania.
The prisoner at Port Arthur Tasmania,
they're sent to Australia.
That's why when the
Australians play the English,
a lot of the Australian sing,
we,
you know,
that Old Beatles Song,
yellow submarine now,
which you don't remember.
I,
which I vaguely remember,
uh,
we,
you know,
we all live in a convent colony,
a convict colony,
uh,
captain swing,
they lost,
but they went down fighting.
And it's bitter hard to write
the history of remainders.
But when you look up
from that and you say,
look what the,
what's going on here?
When you look at people
fighting for grain,
fighting for food,
they're fighting against the
larger process that they can't,
they can't control,
but it tells you a lot what's
going on over the big picture.
So that's another one.
And then there is just,
I'll just take one more,
uh,
maybe another 10.
I'm going to read my poem and they then,
then you can go.
But I hope you come back.
Um,
war war as a dynamic of change.
the 18th centuries,
what warfare changes with Napoleon?
Uh,
there were already changes
in the 18th century,
but it was still basically professional
armies are people getting conscripted
into the British navy because they
were drunk at the wrong place,
at the wrong time,
outside of a tavern in
Portsmith or something.
And next thing they know,
they're throwing up on a,
on a ship bobbing off,
uh,
it sort of the English empire,
but,
but warfare changes with the nation state.
The French called it [inaudible].
That's her mass conscription,
the sense of defending the nation.
And there's this magic moment where
the artisans of Paris defeat the,
you know,
highly professional art lies army
at a windmill called Vat and me,
uh,
in the east of France.
And it changes the way things were.
A Napoleon is arguably
the first total war,
uh,
because of a war against civilians,
in,
uh,
where they're no longer the traditional
limits between fighting against
civilians in fighting against the,
uh,
against armies and other,
those limits hadn't existed
in the 30 years war.
And I'll talk a little bit about that,
uh,
a next time around,
but,
but the wars are very different.
You know,
there were,
there's famous Goya paintings of,
of a peasants being gunned
down by French soldiers and,
and atrocities against
the peasants in Calabria,
in the south of Italy.
So warfare really changes,
but it becomes a dynamic of change.
If you think about the
Russian revolution of 1917,
the Russian revolution was not
inconceivable without world war one a,
but it was sort of inconceivable
without the Russian revolution of 1904,
nine,
I have 1905 in the feet in
Japan by the Japanese and,
and an extraordinary,
uh,
shocking event for,
at least for Europeans in,
in 1904 1905.
And World War One provides opportunities
for dissidents in Russia to put forward
their claims.
So when the whole thing
collapses on the czar's head,
uh,
in February,
1917 and the Bolsheviks come to power,
the war itself with the
dynamic of change as well.
And what a war,
uh,
what wars,
I mean,
there had been nothing ever like it.
A few journalists who had been in,
uh,
the Russian Japanese
war had seen trenches,
uh,
in,
in Manchuria that had been built,
but nobody could have imagined that
the ward was supposed to be over in six
weeks,
was going to destroy four empires.
Uh,
that is the,
the,
the Ottoman Empire,
the Austro-hungarian Empire,
the German empire,
and the Russian empire.
And arguably this,
we can talk about this.
We can debate this,
the British empire,
because lots of people
who had fought in India,
oh,
Indians who had fought in the war,
or people now we'd call Pakistani's
who'd fought in the war,
or people from Kenya
who fought in the war,
uh,
are no longer going to be satisfied with,
was simply,
you know,
arguing that they're part of the,
of the great empire,
even though they have,
have,
uh,
hardly any rights and no
money and simply work for the,
uh,
for the big guy.
Um,
and so the war transforms,
uh,
Europe by destroying these empires.
What it also does and is
very possible to argue this.
And,
and,
um,
and my friend Jay Winter,
who is great expert on world war one and
Bruno and combine also who's on leave
this year would agree with this.
You can see the whole period in 1914,
1945 as a new and more karabal 30 years'
war because Europe is in depression all
through the 1920s and thirties,
agriculture,
depression the whole time,
uh,
only between 1924,
1929 is it not big industrial depression,
uh,
the poisoning of the political atmosphere.
I'll give,
I'll talk.
I'm going to do a whole lecture on Hitler
and the National Socialists Cause War.
Ro One created Hitler.
He was already just as pathetic a guy
with great grandiose plans with no friends
and,
and that sort of a sad sack
going to the theater and uh,
and a of droning on and on
about all I knew about Wagner,
who we loved and in the theater
and in a threadbare coat,
but world war one transforms
him into an anti-semite.
He was already an anti socialist.
It transforms a Munificent,
anti-semite people,
the troops that came back,
many of them simply kept on marching.
They'd survived the war,
and they kept on marching,
marching and the poisoning
and the political atmosphere
was something that was
simply extraordinary.
And you have to under understand fascism.
This is terribly,
terribly important.
Uh,
you have to understand what
happens in world war one.
Great expectations dashed,
uh,
the treaty of Versailles,
which only the great British thinker,
John Maynard Keynes really got right
predicting the disaster that came out of
it.
If there's no more
fascinating period in history,
uh,
in my mind,
it's,
it's absolutely a fantastic,
and what a war.
It's all obvious.
Everybody's seen these films,
imperial or war museum,
which has been kind of wreck
the way they've done it.
Now it's sort of too high tech,
but a in London.
Uh,
but it,
I leave you with just a couple of thoughts
that the battle of the Somme in 1916
that started in July 1st when they blow
the whistle and say over the top guys,
uh,
there are more British soldiers killed
and wounded in the first three days of
the battle of the Somme,
Som m e three days,
three days.
Then there were Americans
killed in world war one,
Korea and Vietnam combined in three days.
Whereas where are the great British
leaders in the 1920s in the 1930s,
they're all dead.
They're hung up on that old Barb wire.
It's one of the war poets put it there
are hung up on that old Barb wire.
One guy,
a soccer player.
I said,
well,
I'm gonna,
you know,
we'll,
we'll get some enthusiasm.
He drives to dribble a ball across,
you know,
these trenches and things
like across the bow,
the craters and he doesn't make it.
He's,
he's killed in 1950,
1914 and Christmas Day.
The Germans and the,
and the,
and the British soldiers,
I'm to say enough of this stuff for the
day and they sing to each other and they
actually play soccer.
They play football.
1915,
or British soldiers says let's do the
same thing and you put him against the
wall and shoot him 19,
the war,
the horror of the war.
Uh,
uh,
it,
it transforms Europe.
Every aspect of Europe.
Uh,
it's impossible to understand
the growth of the agrarian,
a sort of semi fascist regimes in
eastern Europe and very much under Nazi
influence,
uh,
without understanding World War One.
Uh,
the war that the supposed to end all wars,
of course it doesn't do that at all.
And that's a big stop on,
uh,
on our uh,
on our agenda as well.
We did,
we used to read all quiet
on the western front,
but everybody's read that and then we
read Robert Graves rather long and self
indulgent,
a good bite,
all of that.
So that was pretty long.
So we don't do that,
but we do,
we will,
we will try to rock.
Let me just read you my
poem and then you can,
then you can go,
uh,
Lincoln,
whatever you want.
But anyway,
but I remember this,
I remember reading this poem,
uh,
back in University of Michigan,
on,
uh,
on two o'clock on a Saturday trying to
figure out what it does in the night
before,
but ain't we know,
um,
this is Brett,
the great,
uh,
East German East German poet,
and it's called a worker reads history.
And let me begin by saying that we're
going to study quote unquote great.
I mean,
really quote unquote great men,
great women.
Uh,
Hitler is obviously not a great man,
but he's a,
you know,
awful,
just awful.
But the people who were thought
to a made history in Napoleon,
uh,
Peter,
the great,
uh,
other people I do talk about the folks
that you read about and in textbooks,
including mine,
but I asked the same question and post
you the same question that Breck poses,
and it's a short poem.
So just hang on.
Who built the seven gates of thieves?
The books are filled with the names of
kings was at kings who hold the craggy
blocks of stone and Babylon
so many times destroyed.
Who built the city up each
time in which of Lima's houses?
The city glittering wood with gold lived
those who built it in the evening when
the Chinese wall was finished,
where did the masons go?
Imperial Rome is full of Arcs of triumph.
Who reared them up over whom
did the Caesar's triumph?
Byzantium lives in song
where all her dwellings,
palaces,
and even in Atlantis of the legend,
the night to see rushed in the drowning
men still bellowed for their slaves.
Young Alexander conquered India.
He alone,
Caesar beat the goals.
Was there not even a cookie in his army.
Philip of Spain wept as his
fleet was sunk and destroyed.
Were there no other tiers?
Frederick the great triumphed
in the seven years war.
Who triumphed with him?
Each page a victory at whose expense?
The victory ball every 10 years.
A great man who paid the Piper.
So many particulars.
So many questions,
and if you hang with us this semester,
we'll get at some of those.
Yep.
Thank you.